welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and loki is
very nearly arrived on disney plus
continuing marvel's tradition of taking
british actors killed off in avengers
infinity war and resurrecting them
through over-complicated logic we
probably still won't fully understand
even after the series ends but hey
that's why i'm here this is my glorious
purpose
dad to explain the trippy timeline logic
that brought loki back to us
because it's really not as simple as him
just going poop out of avengers in-game
that movie left a lot unexplained about
its timeline logic that we have been
trying to piece together with these
various disney plus series now don't
worry there will be no spoilers for any
episodes of loki in this video our after
show and my easter egg breakdown will
come out next on the channel but here
i'm gonna explain the logical framework
that loki
is operating under because they're not
just saying it like lots of time travel
stories are they're actually trying to
make it make sense
first and then saying now we know the
loki series picks up with the god of
mischief
after his escape during the time heist
and avengers end game when he snatched
the tesseract after the avengers fumbled
it
and vanished but if loki was using the
space stone to teleport to a different
point in space and he didn't move
forward or backward in time or
portal into a new dimension or timeline
at least by the looks of the trailer
footage he just goes to mongolia why
is he now in trouble with the time
variance authority
and how did the actions of captain
america at the end of adventures end
game with the tesseract and the other
infinity stones
affect loki's new path with avengers end
game the marvel cinematic universe
embraced a
new type of time travel logic that i
refer to as the type 2
branch timeline approach why type 2
because it makes you go look what type 1
was
go watch that video please branch
timeline is loosely based on
the many worlds theory of theoretical
physics where there are actually an
infinite number of parallel universes so
unlike time travel stories like the
first fact of the future film or
terminator
where all the time travel shenanigans
take place along one historical timeline
that warps or erases things within that
timeline in
branch timeline fiction going back in
time and
changing things in the past causes an
alternate branch history to split
off leaving that original timeline
unchanged performing a
multiverse of parallel realities when
the avengers went back in time to steal
the infinity stones from history with
each of those changes they actually
created a new branch history remember
the ancient one
warned them that at the end of their
mission they would have to go back
again and return each stone in order to
clip
off each branch now in loki the tva
calls this the
sacred timeline and they use a very
similar visual for it and they appear
similarly
fearful of a chaotic multiverse and
instead prefer the flow of time to be
kept within one
sacred timeline so when loki takes the
tesseract the original marvel timeline
as we knew it the sacred timeline
continues on
unchanged but this loki now becomes
a variant who drags his whole universe
around him
along with him into a skewed branch
timeline
that threatens the original sacred
timeline now the reason this did not
happen with the avengers is in
endgame cap followed the ancient ones
rules and restored the sacred timeline
by returning each of the stones from
when and where they were taken
and by doing so each branch timeline
that those stoneless histories were
on rejoined with the main sacred
timeline now sure it requires a bit of
speculation here because the endgame
filmmakers kept that restoration
off screen really because a lot of those
stone returns would have been pretty
awkward to digest during the film's
final emotional beats like think about a
cap would have had to go to 2012 to give
the time stone back to the ancient one
no problem there but then
he would have had to bring loki's
scepter with the mind stone back to the
shield agents he took it from
knowing fully well that they were
corrupted by hydra and then he would
have had to put the power stone back
into the magnetic
field on morag not a big deal but then
he would have had to inject the reality
stone
ether back into jane foster on asgard
yikes and then he would have had to go
to vormir to confront his old buddy red
skull as he returned the soul stone to
him
and then he would have had to return to
1970 and flip the tesseract back into
the shield basement container and like
re-welded it shut after tony stark had
taken it yeah i know it's
a mess and it is this mess that the loki
series is dive and head first into
because
loki's tesseract snatch represents an
unfixable breach to the sacred timeline
but before i continue i
am trying to eat better which means
trying to avoid extra sugar which stuff
because of sugar is
perfect and wonderful but i can't eat it
all the time that's why i am eating
magic spoon cereal
it's got no junk in it but it tastes
really good like almost too good for how
healthy it is
zero grams of sugar 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving
also only 140 calories it's gluten free
gmo free and free of the other stuff
that you're really not supposed to have
i really like this peanut butter flavor
because it is it's just like the peanut
butter flavored cereal that i used to
eat as a kid well like not terrible for
me
also on the new rockstars team have a
little debates over what flavors are our
favorites
right now i am on team peanut butter
others are on team coco
i don't know who i'm yelling at i'm
working from home but yeah we're real
spoon heads over here so click that link
below and get some magic spoon cereal
today you can build your very own
variety box and use the code new
rockstars for five dollars off
you could choose from the best-selling
cocoa fruity frosted or peanut butter
flavors plus lots of other awesome
flavors including blueberry and cinnamon
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked so click that
link below and use the code newrockstars
for five dollars off or go to
magicspoon.com
new rockstars to save five dollars off
your order today hey and for our
canadian fans magic spoon is now
shipping to canada
why is it unfixable well loki's destined
path was to go back with thor
to asgard to get imprisoned allow friga
to get killed by the dark elves and then
break out and help thor niflheim fake
his death and then secretly replace odin
and then get caught and watch odin die
and then escapes a car with thor hulk
and valkyrie and then summons serger to
destroy asgard and then steal the
tesseract and give that tesseract to
thanos who then kills him but by
escaping
loki altered that destiny and he took an
infinity stone with him
which also altered that stone's destined
path of
being in camp lehigh in 1970 then in the
hands of windy lost in the late 80s then
powering the skrull space station and
earth's orbit from 89 to 95
then swallowed by goose the flerkin from
95 to the mid-2000s we think
then experimented on by nick fury under
project pegasus until 2012
then reclaimed by the avengers and take
him back to asgard with loki and stored
in odin's vault
until loki steals it again in 2017
during ragnarok and gives it to thanos
an infinity war in 2018. but by taking
the tesseract to 2012 and fleeing loki
altered that history
removing the infinity stone from its
timeline and himself from his timeline
with the reality he is now in
in this loki series part of a new branch
history so it doesn't matter that loki
went through a portal in space and not a
portal in time or a portal to realities
he nonetheless created a new sequence of
events
contrary to what the sacred timeline
dictated and therefore the tva considers
him
an unclipped branch one lingering
violation from endgame that cap
could never restore like despite cap
returning the space stone in 1970 that
space stone still would have made its
way through history to
2012 into the hands of loki who escaped
with it now again why is this
unfixable well loki could theoretically
go back himself
and fix that variance but he would have
to re-surrender himself to the avengers
and i am guessing that after watching
that alternate life play out
in the tva time theater this guy's not
gonna want to return to
a life where he is destined to get his
neck snapped by thanos
so really the problem is that the tva as
we see in trailer footage
shows loki that destiny essentially
guaranteeing that he would never want to
return to it so while it is
loki who first breaks the timeline it's
the tva
who keeps it broken at least temporarily
to use loki to help them with this
greater timeline
crisis and realistically based on the
nature of chaos and the fact that this
loki variant probably isn't gonna go
back to a historical path we've already
seen him on
but rather some other future as this
series is gonna live on at least for a
second season
i don't think this sacred timeline is
gonna last forever and a true
marvel multiverse including variant
loki's and
variant avengers variant all of these
characters is
now as we look ahead to doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness
much like the rule breaker who kicked
off this crisis
inevitable hey check out one of our
great loki inspired merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter eavos
follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis and
breakdowns of everything marvel thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you